bonjour à tous agen 2016 nationale
aujourd'hui je suis avec le grand maître
international yannick gozzoli salle
yannick salut stéphane super début de
tournoi pour toi ouais pas mauvais mais
c'était faux le résultat aurait pu être
aussi bien inverser les choux et pascal
or hier tu as fait quand une partie
vraiment superbe face à laurent
frayssinet parce qu'on ne te voyais
quand même mais on se voyait donc vous
voyez tout ce dont ils vont peut être en
difficulté laurent avait pris un pion tu
pour la tête tu avais pas donner un pion
pour l'activité mais n'a pas réussi à en
tirer parti
et puis finalement tu as réussi à tenir
une finale difficile ouais enfin milieu
de jeu je devais ok c'était normal en
voiture et en fait j'ai un peu trop je
fais une grosse erreur de calcul en
milieu de jeu quand j'ai joué le foot
bessette et qu'il a le tour était déjà
prévu que je fous ces 8 mais j'ai oublié
un truc qui m'a enfermé le fou
maintenant et après il a fait je vous
défends d'évoquer la finale des perdants
entre même quasiment jusqu'au bush père
dans mais il s'est trompé je pense à des
erreurs c'est quand y fait qu'à
l'étranger s'est tout de suite s'il
aurait pu peut-être joué b4 d'abord en
échec un moment dans la finale d'accord
on a regardé vite chez ça avait l'air un
peu compromis mais ouais je pense que ça
doit perdre donc c'est un bon résultat
car oui oui ça fait partie comme sa et
acheter très content d'avoir ça de cette
position mais j'étais un peu déçu enfin
j'étais un peu inquiet pour aujourd'hui
par rapport à mon jeu wii et surtout par
rapport à ma forme actuelle qui est pas
terrible et par rapport à la forme de
sébastien qui est assez exceptionnel
depuis ces huit derniers mois mais qui a
fait une super partie hier d'ailleurs
partie magnifique d'ailleurs il avait
fait c'est assez marrant parce que la
dernière je pense à saint quentin il
avait fait la même
le même type de partie et la première
rencontre ils sentaient secours ouais
avec sept fils de qualité sur le long
terme et non mais bon on voit ça tous en
son genre en contrepartie c'est un très
bon copain en plus et c'est un joueur
que je redoute pas sûr et donc cela oui
aujourd'hui je suis particulièrement
content même si bon on va voir par là
aussi c'est une très belle partie qu'on
a pris beaucoup de douala
c'est assez spectaculaire mais au niveau
correction encore une fois mais sa série
pas d'erreurs ça serait pas marrant
voilà donc alors c'est parti des 4 oui
mais bon si ce n'est pas vraiment une
surprise je sais que sébastien serment
il s'est mis à dos la nuit the beach oui
ok c'est un spécialisé l'estonienne bien
sûr donc bon je voulais quelque chose
sur l'estonienne mais j'avais prévu
comme ça aussi mais il m'a surpris assez
rapidement parce que des 500 kg 3
d'accord tout était prévu j'ai prévu de
changer par l'annoncé d'accords c'est
ouais bah ouais comme vierge est devenu
un pion pour pour l'activité devant eux
et à 6 voilà c'est la surprise je
m'attendais à ses 5 requis la veille de
plusieurs fois d'accord
ah oui tu t'attendais manque maintenant
je m'en rappelle plus de ce qu'il
fallait jouer donc j'ai joué cavalier le
5 parce que j'avais des petites ouïes
les petites des petits reste 10 d où l
idée de carrière c'est notamment c'est
qu'on peut pas jouer des scènes déjà
ouais mais tu veux sur ok en fait tu
peux aussi simplement jobé 5 parce que
dans ses positions
normalement il faut pas parce que enfin
aussi tu me dis les coûts plutôt parce
que c'est un instinct magicien le
spécial à la place de jeu et qui avait
les yeux sans que tu peux jouer mais un
peu rauque et aussi des gens juste
heureux quand et quel c6 maintenant oui
et là ok il ya plusieurs schémas qu'elle
c3 où le coût 3 et le coup et 3 il est
intéressant parce qu'il permet de nous
trois qui pourrais tu veux jouer dans
me2 provoqué b5
reid à cordes amériques d'amnesty et
après tu vas essayer de jouer b3 c'est à
dire que tu vas même donné le pion
est-ce qu'il faut qu'il aura joué b5
pour la colonne sait qu'il sera très
faible
d'accord donc tu vas donner le curé
jouer sur laquelle ces cinq là comment
les noirs sont qu'elles peuvent s'ils
peuvent se libérer mais c'est un petit
jeu c'est un jeu sur les compensations
si un plan mais je voulais pas voir ça
contre sébastien parce qu'il avait
vitesse et enfin pas jouer vite à 6 mais
il a quand même voici ce qu'est une
tendue et je me suis dit que bon il est
certainement mieux préparés pour là
dessus vente et c'est le contre
surprendre en fait ouais j'ai essayé
d'obtenir une position je lettre à
l'aise en fait ouais parce que même s'il
était préparé je me suis dit bon ok
c'est des positions assez dynamique avec
du contenu des compensations donc j'ai
joué cavalier ou 5 il a joué ou les
quatre chiens cube et 4 l'alternative
c'est 5 c'est l'alternative dont je me
rappelais d'accord tous les cas je me
rappelais plus je crois que j'avais vu
en tous genres sud et de ici oui mais
c'était avant
et donc j'ai joué qu'à et c3 quelques
naturel de coin tranquille mais on a
joué façon tu développes les pieds mais
c'est avant tout parce que là ils
gardent le pion de manière forcée parce
qu'elle a gagné 2,5
oui car les dessins qui te met la
pression et il ya déjà 20 de baisse et
qui bloque qui bloque effectivement la
roue donc besson qui est possible on
accroît donc allée des cinq attaques le
pré vallier fou des deux îles quasiment
forcé et là maintenant effectivement
comme lecavalier viennent bloquer cette
action avait un garde le pied 5 est
possible mais il ya des il ya un
problème entre reparti et qui va être
objets plus ou moins donner ce fou de
gasoil est donc en fait ça va avoir une
joie une certaine compensation dans sa
vapeur de fou le centre et des pièces un
peu plus active oui donc le problème
c'est que si les conversions ne tiennent
pas je vais avoir le coeur net de - oui
ça ressemble beaucoup à la partie d'hier
c'est ce qu'on se disait c'est la donnée
encore en millions oui pour du dynamisme
du célibat il n'est pas venu pour
rigoler alors laurent pendant la paf un
peuple vers la fin la partie il m'a dit
qu'il allait m'appeler au legs honeywell
parce que oleg ses élèves roumanie chine
un grand maître ukrainien très fort qui
est spécialiste de ce genre de bande
lité qui me disait justement qui donnait
tout le temps le pion s'est cassé puis
la pluie a joué comme si de rien n'était
d'amélie si tu continues comme ça je
t'appelais oleg je prends pas ça comme
un compliment sur ses complices mais
voit ont vu la partie je pense que
roumanie chine ne serais pas très fier
d'avoir donc là j'ai appris au tyrol à
los angeles de prendre des cinq fois et
oui parce que maintenant
l'échec quand il ya le fou qui serait en
attaque mais surtout faire attention
donc de l'apli qui prend je vais prend
alors l'intérim est sûr c'est que tu
ramènes un pur vers le centre donc c'est
très bien défendu au centre tu vois sans
doute joué quatre ça tape quand même une
belle bel ascendant savalli la paire de
fou mais le problème c'est que j'ai pu
le pousser b3 maintenant à oui on peut
plus casser la structure alors avantage
c'est que le pire des cas demain dre
surprotégé par le pion c3 ça ressemble à
aussi à la structure de 2 hier
ah oui sauf que j'appelais il ya plus de
pièces ouais mais bon c'est sébastien
était content parce que bon il avait une
très belle partie hier j'imagine bien
qu'il en multi d'envisager de mola d'en
gagner une belle aujourd'hui aussi mais
même fameux si elle était belle deux
gagnants tout cas oui
et ensuite ça lui permettait de prendre
une belle la tête de lobito à quoi bien
sûr que oui voila moi j'avais besoin de
me remettre en confiance et lui il
fallait qu'ils confirment est bon en
face on fait toujours des partis un peu
folle tous les deux oui est bon c'est
bon c'est la remarque l effet mathieu
cornet tiers ans il faisait aussi il
avait joué ouais sur sa partie où il
faisait aussi des partis un peu folle
bah oui donc là j'ai joué alors déjà à
part cela je suis juste un autre bouc
j'ai juste joué seul fait je savais pas
quoi faire et j'ai joué quatre qui me
semble être un coup logique parce qu'il
faut repousser ce cavalier en dessin oui
c'est bien mon émission n'occupe le sens
parlant le problème de cas ça bouge un
peu la diagonale oui ça c'est le gros
inconvénient mais l avantage par contre
c'est que maintenant en jeu gagnant en
espace les maintenant je vais changer
j'ai changé mon fusil d'épaulé je vais
emmener le jeu sur l'album et je mets de
la pression sur la structure noir on
s'est posé la question nationale canalis
pas évident
angers 5 salaires en bref si je pense
c'est très douteux parce que la foulée 5
qui va arriver
voilà il ya foule g5 qui peut arriver ça
glisse d'affaiblir le rock un peu
anglais s'ils sont si c'est possible
aussi mais mais on s'éloigne du rock on
a peur de se faire prendre une attaque
un peu cavalier 7 c'est un compromis
quoi en fait c'est un bon ou pas ce qui
porte à jacasser s'il peut aller en
justice en cas d' attaques d'eric soul
rock et ensuite les cavaliers sous il ya
plus de souplesse combes et 600 blessés
si ce plaisir est au centre
donc là j'ai joué à 4 à 4 bien battus
quand même tu chatouille un peu cette
soirée mais c'est hélas je suis pas du
tout sûr dont nathalie c'est d'abord ici
c'est plus précis puissant si je fous le
set je vous donne bien tout de suite
avec la menace qu'elle pensait que tu as
oui c'est arrivé ça nous allons avoir un
peu dans la partie de son personnel
avant f6 jouer f6 que j'ai calé g4 on a
peur on peut quand même là parce que
c'est un peu faible en europe mais bon
c'est vrai que le fou là il est quand
même pas axée sur l'europe est un petit
peu mais bon ça suffit pas quoi non mais
le problème c'est que je peux pas monter
la table solo rock et leurs trois pièces
de défense il échoue mais sait-on
laissant ses nombreux au lead to b 7
là j'ai joué là je suis pas sûr du tout
de ma conception dont j'ai joué deux
hommes b 1
mesdames bien c'est bien alors dans le
tome 2 1 c'est bien tu tu protèges le
cas mais sur qui et surtout tu fait
pression sur cette colonie ci est bon
pujol est à cap des 1 la tour et tu
espères smith est assez important
puisqu'il a joué un très bon coup il
vous donne 17 17
et là j'ai joué tour d un parce que
justement je voulais déjà joué cavalier
de trois ans mais y'avait c-53 c5 est le
fruit de deux ans leur ayant même la
dame protège le fourbe et cette voix là
alors que tout redevient le fou n'est
plus en l'air voilà c'est pas la même
messieurs si les accords d un fou à
noter donc ça protège le fou et en plus
ça mais la tour en vis-à-vis là
exactement
et là je suis pas sur fond coup du tout
mais alors
il a joué le jeu ce soir beaucoup oui
parce que là tu vas trouver une belle
idée ben j'ai pas mal de belles idées je
pense ici mais je pense que la position
blanche avait déjà favorable à ce coup
parce que c'est trop tôt pour ouvrir le
centre mais oui ces évacués sont fourbes
et c est en faute oui oui parce que tu
va le tuer avec 10,1 voilà c'est vrai je
montre avec une structure favorable à
l'homme et la paire de fou donc voilà
donc déjà un joli coup fois je crois
parce qu'attendre est le cas elle était
attaquée on avait deux solutions soit
levée soit x 3 x 3 bien sa menace elodie
il aurait pu jouer à la place de jouer
revient oui à la place de jouer eux 5
ce qui est important c'est que en fait
la pression aurait assez passive le
kylie peut pas se développer parce que
toujours b5 en l'air ouais et donc du
coup si je vous sais 6 par exemple avec
l'idée de tout protéger sa meule of sam
bouche comme la vouge son four et
maintenant je vais jouer un coup comme
fou c'est un par exemple et je vais
remplacer mon fou sur la belle diagonale
à trois maîtres mots font assez
s'arrêter sur coup j'ai décroissent
compensation à long terme
oui allez maintenant aux 5 est possible
confie qu a eu vent de ce qui est
possible ce fou qui monte oui c'est très
passif en fait c'est pour ça que la
position noir allaient passer simple à
jouer les actions de plus mais il a du
mal à terminer son développement mais
bon au sein ok je suis pas sûr que ce
soit un bon coup mais ouais c'est sans
doute c'est dangereux parce que à tout
moment maintenant tu peux prendre ici
avec un vis-à-vis tour dames juste je
cale de trois de nos livres car il y
trois années sans doute jouable si
c'était mon idée initiale bien sûr avec
il est si prend des cats jeu reprend
juste et je me laisse quand même qu'elle
pense et 4 m en fous va arriver sans
décote
louis et moi âgées j'hésitais entre les
deux ça menace aussi qu'elle est pensée
grecque mais sur ses biens mais forget 3
c'est pas mal parce que finalement la
dame bien protégé à 4 tu tues tu donnes
notre des gones à l'as où tu menaces
légales inda c'est quand même bien oui
passage est là et il est là je vois
beaucoup les joueurs et là je dois me
vite on a plus joué pts et 3 je suis
alors roi je suis tu je faisais
piotrovsky on prend un cercle rouge à
côté on prend 1,5 faut bouger la main
problème voilà allez peut être attaqué
la même qu'avant baker la dame qui veut
revivre et donc ça fait c'est dangereux
donc vers les amériques
mais là il faut pas tomber dans un piège
parce que si je prends 5 je pense que je
suis quasiment va je pense que je suis
dans les punchs lui offrait des hells à
ce que la souveraine s'est passé les f-5
parce que justement la main invisible
abdou tend un micro laps de temps moi et
mes pièces mois fourrage froid est mon
cas les dangers guettent son mal placé
il menace damas cinq à tout moment oui
en plus la cfu prend qui menacent
exactement très pénible donc on est
quasiment obligé de prendre
elle a juste il peut jouer c'est dommage
ça y est on voit tout de suite déjà qu
un ca libéral france se fout de la
gueule et la vida match st louis damages
5 gb oui parce que le foot justement
empêche le roi de venir défendre
c'est pour ça que le fourrage trois
montes et surtout de virer la dame gamme
a8 et maintenant cavalier le 3 et je
pense que maintenant les blancs un
avantage de trading très très pro toutes
les pièces sont maximales devraient se
fout en plus humaine en est à la limite
il est plus actif 1 h 3 quand j'ai deux
fils que j'aurais fait la voix ranger
deux sexes pour france je pense que
carrillo 3 était pas mauvais coup à la
baisse deux fois je crois
ouais mais il peut à chaque fois il peut
je me fous s'est vite parce qu'en fait
s'en fout il est mal placé par rapport
aux vis-à-vis avec madame way et chaque
fois qu'il va jouer sous ses buts je
vais devoir pas d'un temps un démon
forget est d'accord donc du coup je
préfère l'avoir rangée de tout de suite
bien sûr mais ça je m'en suis rendu
compte après d'accord et bon ok je pense
que les blancs en avantages déjà net
quoi parce que là la position non elle
est très difficile mais d'ailleurs
sébastien il a plombés
très longtemps bonjour a ensuite par la
suite on s'est lancés se poser la
question avec manu la piste et la cie
pour la suite il a peur de tout ici
c'est chez lui il ya plein de thèmes où
je peux faire des cahiers français 4 et
les échecs de rang b 3 ans que là ils
évitent lycée les dunks ou
prophylactiques quoi
mais qu'a l'air quand même pas si faim a
sans doute pas le souci de gestion et
les critiques ce qui m'a dit d'ailleurs
lorsqu'il était déjà très mal et déjà
hélas tutu le fou des cinq là là c'est
une décision difficile parce que
j'enlève la pression au centre nantais
veut dire que maintenant je vais cloud
qui pouvait pas prendre ici un c4 tout
sujet envisager de prendre ce cote mais
il prend des quatre il joue au f5 prend
avec des cas puis on prend et ensuite
avec quand même un jeune musicien
d'activer ces pièces c'est ce que je
jouais des 5 parce que je me suis dit
qu'au moins il est plus contre jeu est
en fait mon absence je le supplie plus
tard oui et j'ai oublié les trucs
incroyables donc la joie beaucoup le jeu
fut invité à givet une erreur je pense
oui je me fous j'ai deux jeux mais on
s'est dit fou f1 allait revenir parce
que ça attaque c4
avec le fou ça augmente la pression sur
ses 4 est toujours un thème parce que et
comment il protège à la fois de bessèges
oui mais j'ai juste que j'ai oublié tout
dans mes calculs parce que j'ai vu fou
g2 ouais donc faisait de l'oeil et la
jouer le seul couche coin car c'est le
seul coup pour son groupe que je pense
prise et puis se développe un peu quand
même
attention il peut aussi si on ne fait
pas gaffe ils peuvent venir à ces 5 et
puis la daube et le quasi si oui mais
l'option ses cartons voilà il a jamais
le temps et à prendre le 5e tour mais là
je pense que j'ai raté un truc mètres
autour des 8 es seul quasiment ce coup
c'est un bon coup puisque le vide en
s'appuyant sur la dame le rayon à 6,70
protégé par le fossé 8
donc ça a l'air de tenir un peu mais
c'est aux blindes jouer bien sûr
non mais là j'ai joué j'étais trop long
je pense alors oui alors on s'est posé
la question dit si j'avais leur âge et
emmenée entre 2,6 et b 6 me et des six
arbitres 6 quand même très peur de tout
reprendre non parce que damas deux tout
simplement damas deux essais 4 à tomber
voilà la fête jusque là bas sa faiblesse
en a six ans que je joue dans la partie
ça lui permet de ramener sa faiblesse en
médecins ouais et du coup moi je voulais
garder les deux les deux faiblesses mais
je sais pas ce que b6 tu mens possible
abc alors b6 on peut regarder d'accord
pourquoi pas dans ce cas il peut prendre
du cavalier dans les rues et là je
l'envisagé kilama tech c4 juste d'amadou
dame mais quatre ans mais tu peux quand
même prendre le cavalier en fait
gigote enfouis quatre intermédiaires
elle protège la tour par l'adam attaque
la tour d un et donc le cavaly ces
cartes est en l'air c'est quoi assez
compliqué quand même
mais cette fois c'est un super joueur
mais en plus tactiquement il est alerte
et ont ils manient des peaux de banane
partout dans la partie et j'ai fait
glisser quelques fautes a failli et la
juste dommage par exemple à baa2 puis
suivi de calais prend c4 et c4 à tomber
l'avantagé d'être assez 7 et à six qui
sont faibles si l'objet de joseph 5 il a
faibli au 5 et puis j'essaie de majorité
sans entraver le processus ajoute à un
seul gros lots de pions et puis alors
lui effectivement il ya deux faits
bléger affaire de faux seins il appert
de foot
ça fait cher quoi donc ici sur tourbe
mlb si c'était intéressant si oui alors
des six était intéressant effectivement
là on a on l'avait envisagé mais plus on
prend donc des six a blij quasiment 1 on
n'a pas le choix parce que sinon il ya
peu on prend 0 avec un gain de temps
qu'il faut prendre ce que je veux c'est
penser que et là maintenant l'idée après
des six et en présence en attaque mais
ici ça va d'autres ambitions qui est
possible puisque je loupais dans me2
vous donne des trois dames 2 2 me de tom
ces deux aussi comme ces deux c'est
possible mais comme ces deux cas et
c'est ça ma douce et bien c'est bien
parce qu on a pas de problème je me
disais juste de mouches dame bouge mais
il va perdre des six camps mais non
c'est pas vrai mais je viens de donner
donc je vais récupérer de 6 gt pas
convaincu de cette finale parce qu'en
fait je peux gagner souvent fois qu'elle
prend 2,6 que les français 8 pts 6 par
exemple il vient h5 way est là dans ce
cas-là calais prend des six et il peut
s'activer non mais c'est un verdure
quand même parce qu'alors donc assez
vite qui attaque et il ya attention sur
fc est aussi bon même si la mission la
dame ouais en fait ouais j'ai de calais
qui domine chez même pas besoin
oui mais il peut y avoir des menaces
comme g4 aussi des trucs comme ça parce
qu'il ya presque un matheux l'étouffer
la wii
non mais même fou et 3 tout simplement
faux et 3es jeux puisque pioncer fouet
trois le bien c'est beau
garde-fou est tellement forte qu'elle
est décidément ce ouais non mais déçu
c'était beaucoup
ça va leur forme tout à fait d'accord
j'ai pensé mais pas facile la tension
commençait à monter en plus il était
très mal autant et donc on a tendance à
ce que donc là tu as joué car les
français n'étaient pas mauvais mais
l'époque époque qui peut être un peu
moins précis quoi qu'ils aient pas
qu'ils font du tout parce qu'en fait je
me suis fait je me suis fait une grosse
faute de calcul alors apprendre et 5e
avec le trouvant normal donc là tu
reviens trois ambiances et - 6 -
pétition parce qu'il a ramené son pur
vers le syndrome ce pion oui mais je
m'attendais à les attaquer l'option ce
set
ah oui ce fameux client avec la tour
avec la tour la donne c'est pour ça que
j'ai joués 2000 avec abc ce qui est un
très bon coup à calais b si ça y est
bondée d'hommes make up keller plus ou
moins logiques et quatre de sept
la dame est bien placé on revient sur
les biens placés mais en fait j'ai du
mal à aller sur les cases important
autres la food & cnt surprotège sahili
les pièces sur le huitième rang il ya
certaines très faible quand même
effectivement mais c'est par ici et là
par exemple je voulais jouer tour à sept
au début ouais je voulais jouer tour à 7
on peut regarder donne des huit d'amd
vite dame ces cinq attaques mais
nouvelle mêlée est cavalier e ses huit
mais gêné alors ce cavalier peut ensuite
attaque la tour est alors si cette eau
peut prendre ces sept mais peut-être
contre attaque la dame c'est ça ah mais
j'ai raté des six tu vois la fatigue
j'ai raté contre 3,7 ce scanner les
jouer et on prend ces sept cavaliers
séka yapo la cote de mme becker avec un
quintette la dame ici la dame
en mai qu'elle va prendre ça qui avait
fait tant leur fuite qui en l'air
l'homme décote et là je me suis arrêté à
tour à vii ou et je me suis dit bon bah
voilà ton rêve cette latence et pas pour
la tour s'en tenait à des six oui
ah oui il peut partir à 7 mm il ya des
six est là et c'est fini elle reste là
tout le temps qui protège et calonne
dessèche pas contents donc ici ses
cheveux de mc5 et pas très possible
parce qu'en plus se baser sur le ccj et
fait une énorme erreur de calcul
donc là il a joué ces six à mal quand
même parce que la dame est quand même
bien placé sénégal si les lensois
toujours mieux mais hélas par exemple il
a joué ces six qui hésite pas très
précis et qui est même probablement
parce que perdre le jeu tu peux encore
jouer des six éventuellement mais ça ça
reste café mais je ne vais pas donner la
case aussi souffre où ça allait tourner
autour de mon vous demandez pas non mais
je voulais garder cette puce aux cowboys
mais le pian des systèmes la tour qui
derrière donc il difficile ouais mais il
faut rester s'il faut que d'éloges la
case 17 et pour l'avancé et ont doublé
le nombre de pièces qui a qui prouve
cette case ouais tu manques de cases
mais peut-être c4 après le fou peut
sortir aussi enfin peut-être
non mais c'est possible et là mais
j'étais très serein après tout rien
d'accord je pensais que j'avais une
position magnifique d'accord et en fait
j'ai raté juste un truc débile parce que
là je me la c4 tout simplement le
caillebotis sur la c4 alors il peut
prendre non pas ce qu'il veut je prends
des buts et je comprends la tour et en
cas de prise de la dame évidemment le
cavalier saute
non mais il souffre là quand même donc
c'est prendre des cinq ont l air bien
oui je prends ces différents et sur une
rampe et aux français par mauvais parce
qu'il le faut gagner en puissance
leur relation est passé maintenant plus
qu'ils ont passé quand même et là on a
tous les deux fait une erreur de calcul
ne sont pas ce qu'ils peuvent le
cavalier à 4 mon calcul était basée sur
le fait qu'il puisse pas jouer comme la
cote admettons qui joue cavalier a
quatre enfants parce qu'il a filé
oublier en fait ça ouais non mais il
peut jouer au hockey je peux revenir en
bécane est un tube ainsi pouvoir faire
tout aussi mais la sorte on prend les
tours seuls huit intermédiaires on
attaque d'abord la dame en a après on
prend parce que évidemment si on prend
tout de suite on prend la tour et le
cavalier temps les vrais mais un coup
intermédiaire bien sûr s'est surpassé
dans la partie des romans justement mais
c'est beaucoup quand les gens de couple
quand j'ai vu ça je le fioul ef-5 fcg
jouer quoi là justement là j'ai joué un
coup pour lui parce que c'était basé sur
mon erreur de calcul
j'ai joué tout racisme qui doit pas être
le plus fou et l'armée tour à six sa
version c'est fini c'est la partie parce
que kyle ses 8,6 mais n'importe quel sac
du quart et dans celui du jeune homme
c'est 7 et jean fabre à tour il ya tout
autant fermé oui mais le cavalier peut
encore protégés n'ont pas non parce
qu'il permet si ce monsieur soit les
deux pièces pour la tour eiffel et a4 et
l'ajustement peut prendre à 4 pas
possible oui et oui à cause de coûts
intermédiaires
voilà donc grosse réflexion parce que
toutes les forces et du coup je loupe
random b4 et la hat a rien de précis oui
tu vas y vas jouer avec 4'' 3 ml le pion
oui parce que là ça commence à venir les
jo ça a commencé un peu j'ai eu un petit
coup plus j'ai joué damas trois
justement en a3 et la position critique
et la f4 qui a aidé un j'ai joué quatre
attention c'est ça devient dangereux
parce qu'il peut il peut tuer le fou
mais ouvre le jeu aussi ça devient
ça devient chaud je pense que ça
équilibre je te donne un peu moins bien
il a joué f3 la position tentant de se
retourner et fait croire est le foufou
f1 cac et prend de 5 2 des 4 as a fait
ça fait mal quand même
ben oui non parce qu'en fait quand tu
regardes la position la position les
pièces d'or sont pas vraiment de la
place et oui bah tu me diras les pièces
blanches non plus mais oui mais en même
temps après ces quatre d'un coup il ya à
tous mais parce qu'ils sont assez bien
harmoniser et ça souligne beaucoup de
problèmes dans sa position
ces quatre c'est pas facile à dire
maintenant que le fouet à faire en f1
alors qu'il aurait pu y aller tout de
suite est encore vert est d'accord très
bien et là il a fait il l'a fait une
erreur voilà il me disait justement ce
dont on discute et quand quand est
arrivé qu'il aurait dû jouer puis on
prend ces quatre cette affaire en fait
il l'a fait il a fait une grosse main il
aurait dû il aurait dû faire qui en
france et 4 et la topologie d'un prend
pour aider ces évolutions seront
discutées lors d'un bain d'encre en
top14 tourcoing cas de oui parce qu'on
gagne 2 pièces faut prendre un cadre
d'un programme d'emprunt et la sabine
composé d'un bébé 3 il a un avis
carrément échange de dames d'accord
possible ah oui tu peux prendre ces 4
ouais mais d'un procès quête d'un
français qui prend le travail est hyper
des 5 alors admettons d'un procès cadre
d'un procès car dans ce cadre là bon
non vous aurez pas si on prend des 1
donc on va faire ici mariant tu es donc
là d'en prendre d'essai et albert de fou
mais j'arrive à me libérer sur la
première offre 8 à ça tu as un problème
avec ça et oui c'est pas facile mais ok
ça donne tout ça va certainement être
techniquement gagnant c'est une tête
d'être techniquement d'ailleurs parce
que je peux jouer
oui mais il faut que des plus madame et
le travail ou ayant vu que je voyais que
je vous dise le fou et flingue jouets
achetés à trois mois et même après ça
s'il arrive à mettre ses tours sur la
victime qui s'est passé même si on vous
donne des trois par an pour protéger bo
4 est vrai on a des problèmes mais il
était en gros c'est ignoble
donc oui il a joué quelque 6,7 et sans
doute moins de pressing j'ai joué trois
sets
et là je pense que j'ai repris le dessus
maintenant oui mais là gros gros
pointages nommé la honda devant naples
on l'a vu des fantômes tous les deux
d'accord il doit jouer cavalier au 6 mai
je prends juste en d5 et j'ai une très
bonne position de mon cavalier va
revenir en haut trop à mon goût arrive
en c3 m'a demandé si ce g28 pièce ne dit
qu'ils vont arriver sur les cases pour
ce patois position compliquée pendant
encore un assez facile à jouer pour les
blancs maintenant parce que la case aux
trois poumons cavani c'est une caste
antastique oui il va l'empêcher tous les
matins j'ai 2 wii qui protège le fou moi
là et ensuite me l'a demandé si ça va
être magnifique et le pion aux 5es de
très très faible donc s'il avance il va
me libérer à diagonale noir commence
donc du coup la twa recette est très
bien placé et là on a craqué tous les
deux parce qu'il a pris en ckd c'est une
des nombreuses tactiques aridha
courrèges et rage et où ils gagnent une
pièce geste oublier gagné psg prix 11,8
prises en belgique
oui mais oui parce que là tout réfuté
tempère highway dame prend et là j'étais
tellement excitée par dom 2 6 ghz pour
se gagner tout de suite
ah oui ben c'était pour ce qu'il est une
bière à tulle a raté ah oui mais ça doit
être bon aussi quand même mais c'est
moins bon parce qu'il vient ton français
c'est de gagner une bataille est finie
la porte il ya rien du tout juste toléré
de suite plus légers parce que la tour
et suite étant prise est notamment
l'auteure djemila d'amour à trois pour
choper la tour sud il ya cette note à ce
moment là quand même
j'attends surtout lui et moi savage
avait cinq six minutes mais voyez
surtout l'attention face à telle
attention attention messieurs mesdames
des c'est pas mauvais mais c'est moins
simple d'ailleurs il a fait qu il a fait
tourner ses huit un tour si vite
j'ai donc là le problème c'est que si je
prends en 17
il joue cavalier si ces intermédiaires
encore une cote boonen alors on regarde
parce que j'ai pas compris je gagnais
sedan prend 17 et cavalli à calais b 6
pro tak madame protège la tour et puis
de matraque la dame protège la tour et
donc en un problème et la torah c'est
déjà quand il ajoute ensuite c'était sûr
froide un ouais
mais ok là j'avais confiance en ma
position donc j'ai joué fouet 3 ou 3 bon
déjà c'est régler le problème de ses
protégés et l'ajout b55 damazin le fou
été attaqués d'emprunt 5 la jeunesse de
tous doit se fout des cadres par
ailleurs mais là tu commences à te dire
c'est pas mal j'ai la tour sur la 7e
elle est protégée je commence à visée g7
savent à quoi je pensais que c'était
fini mais à tort parce que manifestement
les coûts voyager avec huit cavaliers
vite et j'ai joué j'ai joué jusqu'à 9 5
qui est peut-être pas le plus possible
et sam hanna smart s'est trompé là il a
fait la faute qui perd tout de suite il
a calé des six de jeu qu'est des 6 ou
émerger si je pensais que ça permet
aussi à cause de freins faut regarder
qu'est-ce que pourquoi perdre et déjà
une âme g5y winsome le serbe qui mène à
ce matin j'avais pensé adam g5 menace
matin j'ai c'est en fait quand je pense
qu'il faut justifier cette mais je
prends cet effet il faut être quatre
piliers du vieux tours 6 ouais ben oui
tout reprend of d'un bref 4,4 menace
reprend 2,6 et d'un premier 5 ha oui il
ya le même thème pour la partie
d'ailleurs le bouger le fou et même des
5 et jusqu'où ça finit là parce que tu
pas facile d'accord mais j'étais content
mon cas viande est justement ce que il
tient des cases
donc il a joué cavalier vite vous
allégez cavalière 6 6 4
voilà et là je me laisse tellement de
choses après font des calculs et 4 alors
tu m'énerves congés cette jeunesse te
prends je souhaite principalement je
dois souvent m6 sera prend j'apprécie ça
avec matt dr guell à quoi je me lasse un
peu tous ces bottines belle partie quand
même impasse que tactiquement et
beaucoup choses badakou toutes les
pièces
regardez là oui toutes les pièces jouent
le cavalier il peut sortir très vite
aussi il
évidemment mais là déjà la tour est au
fouet la dame sont déjà super actif
la dame aussi attaque le fou enfin on ne
peut pas bouger beaucoup il veut pas
autant oui il faut pas autant c'est
parce que toujours besoin avant l'heure
la dame est oui pour des jeux plus le
chou b5
il oblige protéger aussi d'autres mots
il est oui il faut profiter à part ça
c'est toujours ça si le détour ce 6 mai
à 20h30 g5 la dame g5 qui joli joli
puisque la menace matin g7
ouais et intégrables en cas de tours ses
7,7 fois tu vas pas rater tout reprendre
tour et après d'âpres en foulant et là
il abandonne oui belle pratique pour des
jeunes fous b5 et en plus quand je
prends le foot des 5es rencontres
qu'ailleurs à 4 il a tout bloqué a
galéré mais il fallu qu'il abandonne
tout à l'heure quand tu pouvais prendre
la pièce sa mort oui mais bon déjà je
suis content qu'il ait que ce soit moi
qui rendrait pas ce que je fais wen a eu
chaud quoi
ouais ouais ceci dit le retournement
hausse et surtout tu as perdu une partie
ton avantage mais t'as jamais vraiment
été savamment jamais vraiment été
totalement retournée c'est à dire que tu
as perdu
je sais pas encore mais les avantages
mais sans s'en sent vraiment perdre le
fil ouais mais c'est pas normal
normalement ce type davantage vous
regardez ses propres quoi donc je suis
bien je peux faire la fine bouche je
suis très content d'avoir gagné mais bon
final après deux rondes
on peut dire que c'est un bon début
surtout que tu as joué deux ouïes de
costauds la dondon freyssinet
oui moi c'est un peu mieux que
d'ailleurs déjà ouais
et non c'est bien le client bien sûr
mais bon ok tournant est encore long et
puis il ya la fatigue qui va entrer en
jeu blanc ouais enfin quand tu confiance
parce qu'on al'impression physiquement
tu tiens à distance quand même je suis
j'ai enchaîné bijane enchaîné deviennent
andorre et le chômage on trouvait donc
je suis assez crever l'arrêt hockey et
j'ai une bonne équipe avec moi donc
c'est cool tu as une équipe de ce mandat
si j'ai un second temps et ensuite on
est quatre on est 5 e dans l'ain dans le
landeronnais loger avec piscine et tout
ça est bonne alors assis à la piscine la
pratique va s'envoler oui n'aura jamais
le soutien et ça fait plaisir et je peux
aussi beaucoup besoin de mon club qui
sont ici et puis j'ai beaucoup personnes
qui me soutiennent
donc ça va m'aider à essayer de faire du
mieux possible mais voilà super ton car
le point là on est très belles parties
seraient votées au début de tournoi pour
toi yannick merci de nous avoir rejoints
au studio diagonale tenais merci de nous
avoir suivis pour cette émission
spéciale
agen 2007 avec donc le grand maître
international marseillais nous président
du club de marseille
me yannick gozzoli qui déjà l'année
dernière avait fait un très un très beau
tournoi et qui est bien parti cette
année merci à tous et à bientôt sur la
google tv au revoir